hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim I know I know I know
it's been a long time I got distracted
by other side projects stuff I was doing
but now I'm back and I'm gonna finish
the game for you guys I know you're
desperate for itself here we go
what's this okay alright that yeah
fantastic
David mods it's been a while since I
play turn over the Dragons means yes oh
yeah to him has returned the worldly
evil even now he devours the souls of
your fallen comrades he grows more
powerful with every soldier slain in
your pointless war yeah you look put
aside your hatred for even one moment in
the face of this mortal danger one
second it is like crazy dark like ah
well that's that's a problem there we go
much better
we're good now
a very pretty speech shut up if he's
right about Oakland
we both have just as much to lose here
Talia's remember that okay now back to
the matter at hand you're the one that
was about to pitch out on me a mug of
sheep's piss and call it Mead these
terms are still not acceptable I'm sure
you have something in mind
uh-huh damn right we do you surrender
for Kree to us okay
sit gear steps down and then gear of
student receives the y'all ship all
right where do these demand stop Ulfric
do you expect me to surrender all of
Skyrim it seems I have no choice but to
let the Dragonborn decide nah [ __ ] yeah
I'm starting to doubt your fan yeah
what say you dragon let's say I how much
it'd be all right let's go the Empire
Bowl could like a truce on the sky
that's right
summon Argonian pose that's the fairest
deal we're likely to get it seems we may
have an agreement okay y'all Ulfric
general Tullius
a these are the terms currently on the
table Marcus will be handed over to
ultrix forces y'all Edmond will step
down and song for silver blood will
become the yarra love maka Stormcloaks
will withdraw from the rift trying
imperial troops unhindered access yo
li'l our lawgiver will step down and
maven blackbriar will become the yarra
love Rifton okey-dokey for Chris will be
turned over to Ulfric and then gear of
stone will return as Yas ask you to me
you both agreed to this the sons of
Skyrim will live up to their agreements
as long as the Imperials hold to theirs
mm-hmm what about you Alyssa are these
terms to your liking speak up
I'm sure general Tullius is waiting to
do your bidding
I have nothing to say to that murderer
general you've proven yourself a good
friend to Skyrim I continue to trust
that you will do your utmost to
safeguard our interests okey-dokey Thank
You yarrow Ellison I appreciate your
loyalty as long as you guys let me kill
drag with these terms yes for a
temporary truce until the dragon Menace
is dealt with right after that Ulfric
there will be a reckoning count on it
cool come on come on yeah I have a lot
of work to do giving up Markarth it's a
heavy price for this truce Dragonborn I
hope it was worth it well obviously
balgruuf I assume you are familiar with
the Dragonborns plan yes I'm ready to do
my part
okey-dokey just say the word and my men
will help you spring this trap oh yeah
I'm a trauma terrifical t remains how
tool you're a dragon - Dragon's reach at
all well that's an excellent question
you haven't overlooked that little
detail of you Giada ah I believe I can
be of help here good old man dissipated
the problem while you were arranging
this meeting okay and I'm guess trove
hmm but the important thing
but the blades recorded many of the
names of dragons with smooth ride
cross-referencing this with Delphine's
map of dragon very sizeable I believe
I've identified one of the dragons that
all winners without cool don't you see
the names of dragons are always three
words of power right shouts by calling
the dragon with the voice he will hear
you wherever he might be okey-dokey
he's not compelled to but dragons are
prideful by nature and loath to refuse
in Shaolin yeah sounds like me your
voice in particular is likely to
intrigue this drug after your victory
overall unable to resist it sounds good
to me I'm no master like these
but it is written here in this Grove
okey-dokey
Oh Davi Windus No
coo-all fast Oh Darby
okay we know Paarthurnax the dragon that
the Greybeards have been protecting okay
he needs to die no he doesn't hurts to
die oh shut up and it falls to you to
kill him false until he's dead
you well I'm sorry but we would dishonor
our owns as blades if we continue to
help you like I give a [ __ ]
make your choice dragon board you're
right here's the big picture he helped
Alduin enslave our ancestors he may have
betrayed Alduin in the end but that
makes him worse not better
Wow we can't afford to give Paarthurnax
the opportunity to betray us in turn and
return to his old master totes makes
sense yeah all right whatever I'm out
here get up get me up let's grow you
lady I don't care what you say oh man
mouse sensitivity is also down there we
go that's better
it has been a long time since I played
but no matter because now we venture
forth into the unknown abyss of Windhelm
where are we going Dragon's reach
someplace to trap the dragon we have
nothing to talk about until Paarthurnax
is damn good didn't want to talk to you
anyway ugly yeah
would you shove your order of the blades
up what
here we go getting it on you guys do say
that I'm like really close to the end
here so who knows like I this has been a
long-running series either because when
I started doing 30 minute episodes it
still got up to like 21 parts so I'm the
commander of the dog care douchenozzle
chaos commander of everyone who's about
to die because I'm gonna bring a dragon
in here okay now let me see you here
there is a new shout I have call dragon
run run I forgotten how to run alt later
gods watch over your battles haha as I
promised my men stand ready the great
chains are oiled oh yeah if you know
what I mean I still remember the whole
dance brigade that happened in here
during the last room if you haven't seen
it it's quite a sight my men know what
to do make sure you do your part okay
I'm putting my city in your hat
okey-dokey
I'm sure I won't destroy everything the
Greybeards have arranged a truce between
the Stormcloaks and imperious ah I've
been out here before I always wonder
what this whole thing was for seemingly
a big open empty area but anyway dumb I
drew that's birdie dust bird
you have a plan for glory
yeah yep here we go that's not the right
one that was wrong this is the right one
give me a second I got to get warmed up
again yeah you that you Delphine the
moon I did it I just did it
hello
oh okay
maybe yes no yeah no there we are
no hey buddy I'm going to
destroy you either hey you let him go
you did bye-bye hello again I maybe
there's a dragon riddle
got ya [ __ ] down here oh oh what's that
oh yeah
oh okay I gotta wait until he's well
inside them okay
come in here
oh that doesn't look so good I've seem
to be failing quite a bit actually okay
quickly aha there we are now what do I
kill him oh I get to interrogate need
amid go down
like a bear in a trap no doubt so creamy
Clinton Bogart rule Vicki Dover I don't
know what you just said ah I forget you
do not have the Dover speak no I could
hear there wants to meet you in battle
was my undoing
Dovahkiin I salute your hmm no cunning
in devising such a crime endure
stratagem aha Goulbourne ah you went to
a great deal of trouble to put me in
this humiliating position ah in sere
Alduin no doubt you want to know where
to find I'll do we may be nice yeah that
would be nice unique Vasa an apt phrase
Alduin Bauval one reason I came to your
call was to test your thorn for myself
okie-dokie many of us have begun to
question all the winds lordship whether
his form was truly the strongest yeah ah
among ourselves of course Moony my a
none were yet ready to openly defy him
hmm once large grossest innumerable
partner lesson I digress he has traveled
to sovereign God to regain his strength
devouring the sillas your way the souls
of the mortal dead isn't sovngarde
wherever and she jealously guards in
some God where his door to solving hard
is that scold often one of his ancient
feigns high in the eastern mountain okay
endure on par akhmad of an hour until I
surely do not need to warn you that all
his remaining strength is martial there
don't matter now mad at Italy lost
orphan inland now that I have answered
your question you will allow me to go
free yeah um serve you no no need it if
and when you defeat Alduin okay I will
reconsider okay hmm grossest roses there
is one detail about scold often I
neglected to mention okey-dokey only
this you have the form of a dov'è ah but
without the wings of one you will never
set foot in scold AfriNIC a bear problem
of course I could fly over but not while
imprisoned like this I like that plan
let's see not just you on the conquer of
kind Malad well you do a wise to
recognize when you really have one
choice wait dude and you can trust me
zooni tell roadies halloween has given
himself unworthy to rule i go my own way
now good free me and i will carry you to
scold often sounds good to me
stop talking let's do this okay how do i
free you how do i incredible
sir you have no idea how long I have
waited for such an opportunity
rastaman I'm most appreciative if you
would permit me to perform some tests on
you
purely in the interests of the
advancement of knowledge it's not bad
begone mage do not test my promise to
the dovahkiin I sure most of them are
hardly painful at all don't do anything
that is yourself you're gonna get rusted
alive what are you doing he's gonna get
this guy's gonna get Mert alized surely
you wouldn't miss a few scales or the
small amount of blood Jimmy what are you
doing back there hang on I'm gonna save
cuz I'm I needed why'd you do that what
the hell
doosh okay how do i free this guy
I see these gears but I can't interact
with them huh no okay
wait oh I've got objectives hang on let
me look at my map local map see custom
destination no set Oh hugga hugga free
how do i what oh maybe I talked to
yarrow you'll be the toast of Whiterun
for this will I okay that's fantastic
now if you don't mind I've got the city
to keep now if you don't mind I'm trying
to figure out how to free this we can
never rest easy
animals okay
Oh up there ah up there how do I get up
there I'll wait there were stairs that's
right there were stairs I got it I got
it I got it I got it I got it I got it
get it go get it I know it's dark I got
it I got it I got a good idea okay I got
it I got it I got it I can't believe
that's work yeah something to tell the
grand
you sure about that yep you want to let
that dragon loose after all the trouble
to catch him in there yep your funeral
yep someone else is gonna have to help
you get him back in there again
okey dokey to open the trap I'm ready
fly me no one asked what are you doing
what are you doing I've had my eye on
you for a while now
anytime roofie you gonna you gonna fly
me right Sarang oof
I await your command as promised aha
i Alice ready to see the world is only a
dov'è conjurer to be pretty night ride
so Britt off
I warn you once you've flown the skies
of Keisel your envy of the Dove will
only increase okey-dokey I might've
caught teens tinsel ah awesome epic on a
right oh we're right address no let me
ride it ah I was hoping for a nice
cutscene or not a cutscene but you know
a guy to like train tour aha that's
disappointing
this is as far as I can take both look
at me look at me look at me okay bye-bye
all right time to murder lies a big
dragon yeah I wish I had mine
I wish Lydia was a no one cares oh no
one cares I've got a destination
and you guys not part of it
oh those old dragons who cares hello oh
no you oh no yo all of fat give me your
shut up Ellen cares about you or
anything you have to say I don't care
what language you're talking I speak
English
speak American God
okay this looks okay there's nothing in
here
never mind yeah
don't make me Oh what I will yeah that's
right you can run away now
should I go
like broken down here come on there's
got to be a way up here that's why this
thing is here right
Oh get all your I've got all the one to
deal with not you guys here we go see
easy as that and blink I guess I
shouldn't be surprised that we're going
to solve an guard well
when we turn up the right that's just a
bit this has been a bit too dark just
for you guys
ordinarily I'd keep it as Massoud
atmospheric but just for you guys so you
can see what's going on
traps like I give a [ __ ] what's that
puzzle gallery
stop running away uh-huh
that's another soul for the file another
soul for the pile Wow something you put
up an almost decent fight a whale a
snake I see a snake up there
and a Boyd - Nick what how many are
there
okay
so I see a whale their choice do these
face that's confusing like a snake here
bird snake whale but there's only three
stones that I see
all right
I don't know which way this is supposed
to face
okay maybe that one's supposed to face
outward so get the whale towards that
one see that one's facing that way with
the snake
and the bird this one's facing a snake
so by process of elimination this should
either be the snake or the bird hey I
got one
oh I get it oh the bird to open that
door and then the snake dopin the other
one okay and it's dark good thing I got
my torch torch torch ding-dong damn
torch there yeah
oh hello useless
I need potions that's what I need for
the fight oh whatever
yeah ariel found it on the winter Wow
must be getting like really close City
Oh what who's that Oh No get ready hi
there
yeah that hurts yeah keep doing that
you're about to kill me a lot of good
that shield did you
[Music]
it would make sense a sovngarde go
through a crypt
just too easy I'm just waiting there
wasn't able to cut it before ya found my
fire breath oh no oh there we go
that aim up I should be using my my Foom
as the dragons would call it hello huh
oh my things already know yeah sorry you
sound a little muffled there okay okay
let's see whale bird whale over here
obviously
to the whale and then the bird over here
obviously bird it's actually almost
always set in the position to away from
what it should be and the snake
that was one okay
like it's not even hard if you didn't
get the clues you could just do it by
process of elimination really quickly it
would not be that big of a deal
fun school dolphin all right now gotta
be getting close
what's that oh that's nice have fun
getting up someone seems to be shooting
arrows at me that's nice
conjures oceans not what I needed
holder come on now ah what the hell
magicka don't need magic ax greater soul
gem sounds good to me
no was that
like God throwing grenades up here seems
like an advance
how come whenever I I have a follow
around my clean like kills every Oh
but when I'm fighting multiple enemies
it doesn't leave these guys aren't doing
a very good job of defending the
interests to sovngarde Oh Oh chit chit
chit don't kill me please don't kill me
oh please don't kill me I'm not I'm not
ready to die I'm not ready to die I
would have been fine I would have been
fine I panicked too soon ah Oh
spaces there hello fire overlord I can
do that too
oh not even close
diamond whoa oh mama
okay ah the claw I gotta look on the
clock no oh what the hell yes I could do
in chance
ah so it looks like a some sort of wolf
a moth anise something another how do i
zoom in on it
there we go hi Fox a moth and a dragon
okay oh that was correct
I'm own God slow oh here we go alright
ready ready for the end ready to go with
sama car and I'm at a time so thank you
all so much for watching as always see
you in the next video and I will finish
this soon so thank you feel much for
watching bye bye bye bye